and a-rollin hey guys welcome to the
making of Mario Kart skate so this all
started a little over a year ago when I
actually got one of these GoPro Gamble's
and it was amazing and I rode around on
a longboard I was like this is so much
fun then I switched it up to 60 frames
per second I was like wow so smooth I
was like I gotta make a video with that
so this would be a lot easier I didn't
actually have to push myself on a
longboard and lo and behold there's a
few companies out there now that make
long boards and the best one is called
boosted they make this electric
longboard that'll go like 20 miles an
hour
super fun super fast Sani if you turn
left really hard I can fall out just
enough I'll owe you that's something you
don't want to do you keep testing it I'm
gonna do some swerves your number one
tip for driving when you're doing these
videos not hit your person trying to
shoot them not here
always assume that the rider has no idea
where the car is I do not personally
endorse what I'm doing I do not
recommend anyone else does this so the
company called Fayette tech actually
makes these gimbals and they're so great
because they're so small so powerful and
keep your footage super steady like I'd
be doing all kinds of like this and you
may notice the camera hasn't moved at
all just the position has changed and
one day I stuck this on a PVC pipe and
you like this big long movie I was like
whoa this changes everything
ideally at each location you get one
going forward one going backwards and
maybe a couple variations in between so
one of the reasons why I wanted to shoot
this at 60 frames per seconds to really
convey the sense of speed that you get
when you are moving that fast it becomes
a little less cinematic sure but it also
becomes way more like a video game
because you get more visual information
as you're going along it does at 24
frames per second one object will be
here in the next frame will be way over
here or is at 60 frames per second it's
here here here you get a lot more
temporal resolution if you will it's
higher resolution in time so why did I
choose to be Luigi over Mario well for
one I'm the only person around here who
can ride a longboard so I needed to be
in the video too I don't look anything
like Mario but I do kind of resemble
Luigi so it made sense to do Luigi and
he's you know I guess the fan favorite
and half of this we need to do some hand
signals here since we're not dealing
with radios the challenge the struggle
in the results for a visual effects oh
my god so so the post-production process
on this video was quite a lot more
extensive than a typical video for one
60fps means two and a half times the
number of frames to render to wide
field-of-view gopro images all
really really hard to track we spent
probably two weeks just tracking the
footage so for the visual effects in
this piece I actually use two different
workflows one is all like the titles in
the big house or symbol yada yada those
were all done an element 3d version 2
from Video Copilot I was able to get it
to look good enough without having to
kick it out to a 3d program to actually
get real ray traced shadows and lighting
and all that but in my opinion the real
magic of the visual effects in this
video are due to this renderer called
octane instead of traditional renderers
that use the cpu to render stuff this
uses the GPU which has thousands of
cores versus like six or eight if you
think about programs like fume effects
or real flow as being you know fluid
simulations octane is a light simulator
so an example that made octane great for
this project is the fact that I was able
to model the simple geometry of the
environment and project textures from
the video onto the walls and that made
it so that you got realistic reflections
and you'll start seeing color from the
walls and the environment bleed into the
green color of the shell if you want to
really in-depth breakdown of what octane
can do check out this video by Kyle
Natal from mega steak man you did the
Game of Thrones Zelda intro if you're
interested in actually trying out this
renderer you can go to their website
right now and try out a free demo in
your web browser play around with the
settings and if you eventually like it I
don't get it absolutely what I do so
because I'm an idiot and can't design
these scenes better I decided to put all
the cool visual effects behind me which
requires rotoscoping and rotoscoping is
the act of cutting out a figure each and
every frame to make sure that whatever
cg stuff you put in the shot is actually
behind your character so what I did for
that was I actually sent out a call to
action on Twitter asking if anyone want
to help out with this video so thank you
so much to the rotoscoping army we got
Adam Natalie Mike Colin Andrew Brendan
Blaine and Christian I really honestly
have done it without you guys so another
person who dedicated a lot of time
helping out on this project is John from
Studio booth nail on top of doing all
the work for the crazy bridge sequence
halfway through the video he also
modeled the shell the Goomba the Bullet
Bill the swamp this is John Studio who
failed he helped out with all the
effects modeled a bunch of stuff and it
was really sweet I couldn't have done it
without him thank you said hey you want
to see Mario destroy a house so John
made those models he sent them off to me
and I animated him rendered him an
octane and positive them back into the
shot mix in all the element 3d titles
I got there's so many effects in this
video I can't think of all of them and
there's so many more effects to do we're
filming this like a week before I'm even
finished with the video I'm going on
hour 20 of working straight
twenty-five hours being awake No
29 doesn't really matter at a certain
point what what does matter what matters
so thank you very much to the artist
savant for letting us use the music
Vario in this video I actually ended up
slicing up the song and put those pieces
to different parts of the video where it
made the most sense and as long as you
cut the song on the beats and have them
blend it won't sound like it's a cut up
song even though it is so a video like
this that is so music central you almost
kind of wonder is there any need for
sound design and the answer is yes but
very subtly so Charmichael layered and
different sound elements like skateboard
wheels screeching tires whooshes a
little bit of Rumble here and there and
once you get that all kinda like mixed
in as if there's no music at all then
you can dial it back to a really subtle
level it may sound like a lot of extra
work but it's almost required for a good
sound design so thank you very much for
watching through this whole making a
video and watching the main channel
video I really appreciate it I kind of
spent my entire soul on this so I'm kind
of just you know gone for the rest of
eternity so this video was actually made
possible by the people who support us on
patreon and if you're interested in
supporting us for future videos you
would surely appreciate it
so also if you want to hit me up all my
social media things are Rendell Reaper
hit me up on Twitter I'm very active
there I see all your comments thanks for
watching
this videos done it's exciting it's
finally done actually it's not done
right now I still got another week but
when you see this will be done ideally